i lived sort of in the south i mean
we're calling oklahoma the south right
because we're here but really we're in
the midwest right there's a way that
things go and and and sort of
traditional routes and you know to buck
the system
it almost feels like it's saying they're
wrong in a way it's felt like that
sometimes
and interestingly enough danica from
women
i'm like hey women you supposed to be on
my side you know right
but that's why i've looked at different
like for example dolly never became a
mother i talk about her a lot i love her
she didn't become a they're just a
choice she made she said i have a lot of
little kids and i take care of well so
do i so i understood that that made
sense to me
you know carol burnett says i can't
imagine not having a having had my
children sure so everybody you know
does it the way i was adopted what if i
change my mind and i decide
to adopt next year which you never know
with me um
there's so much love to go around in
this world i i mean it seems like i'm
curious about your relationship with
spirit as well as spirituality as well
as religion because you know from what i
can gather you don't necessarily believe
in all facets and
structures and beliefs of religion um so
i'm curious about spirituality and where
that fits in
into your life um but you definitely
seem like someone that like stays pretty
fluid and stays pretty um
open
and
and and and fluid not only from a from a
from a perspective standpoint but also
even just from a physicality standpoint
physical standpoint where you're like um
you know even just not doing broadway
for too long like you know they want to
sign you up forever and you're like hi
you've got five minutes and then i'm
gone i love that word by the way and i
know it's and i'm i'm learning all the
the new terms like i know pivot is a
really big big word right now i'm using
it a lot so let me pivot back to the
subject one of the things i will say to
you danica about me and
this journey because really we're all on
it we're all on our own path and
everybody's
dealing with their own crap i don't mean
to go i don't mean to go down low i'm
sorry but i'm gonna say this with faith
i've questioned my faith sometimes
because i've been sad and i've battled
depression before and i think it's
important to talk about because it's a
real thing i had fire across my face you
would run and say oh my gosh how can i
help you but mental health is just
because we can't see it doesn't mean
it's not there and
just having someone to talk to and say
is it okay that i question that or you
know i have that person in my life the
things that i've that i love to do which
i'm a puggy person i like to touch i'm a
big like lover i
i love to sing uh
you know all the things and that's how i
made my living too
it's like oh i'm being told no
no and that caused a real seven week of
like
well how are you gonna get back pulled
back up how are you gonna lift yourself
back up
and i you know i'm not a walking quote
but i have quotes that stick in my mind
oh if you remember john edward the um
the uh politician his wife who's no
longer with us she passed away cancer
elizabeth
yeah i met them or anything
but she has a quote that goes like this
it goes
she stood in the storm
and then when the wind did not uh blow
her way she adjusted her sails
and i think
if you could sum up my whole career
and ups and downs and because that's
what it is and life
it would
i've i'm really good at
adjusting myself
where do you get that from
i have two i have great mom and dad
um i saw my dad
make his business build it up lose it
and rebuild it i saw my mom work her
butt off to help him make that dream
come true i saw them work hard so that
my brother and i could go to soccer and
i could go to ballet and whatever else
thing i wanted to do and there were
times when we didn't get to do that i
could have never could have never
afforded to go into new york danica and
sing a rock broadway show
so what we did is we went to tulsa and
when the show came through we
we'd go see that but that's why it's
important for me you know when we talk
about
kids in our life and being a mother
i have a camp in my hometown i brought
in broadway boot camp and it's hard i
mean people audition they get in it's
grown it's eight years we just had it
wow
it's really it's grown we had seven
countries because we went virtual this
year and 33 states usually it's just
oklahoma but that to me is like okay you
passing it along helps you pull yourself
up
it's a selfish thing really
pulls yourself and it can pull you out
of sadness giving to others sounds
really
weird to say but when you give
to others it's actually
reverse psychology on us it works it
makes us feel better right
but you can't do it for that reason
though right
no no but no you've got to do it when
when the spirit takes you or like
they'll help that person it's like when
somebody asks you to say a prayer and
you go and i do it and i actually
believe it
then
like there's so magic and believing i
mean there's magic sauce in that right
i couldn't listen you or i would not be
where we are today oh yeah if we didn't
believe
in something greater than ourselves
if we didn't believe in the power of
training and hard work if we didn't
believe that we were in a man's world
believe me